dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA in the film
industry we can often see footage of a
human walking on the moon fighting
underwater or appearing in any
environment without actually going there
to do this a piece of footage of the
actor is recorded in front of a green
screen and then the background of the
scene is changed to something else this
process is called green-screen keying
and in theory this sounds simple enough
that make no mistake this is a
challenging problem here's why issue
number one is that separating the
foreground from the background is
non-trivial and is not a fully automatic
process let's call this semi automatic
because the compositing artist starts
drawing the separation masks and even
though there is some help from
pre-existing software it still takes
quite a bit of manual labour for
instance in this example it is extremely
difficult to create a perfect separation
between the background and the hair of
the actor our eyes are extremely keen on
catching such details so even the
slightest inaccuracies are going to
appear as glaring mistakes this takes a
ton of time and effort from the side of
the artist and we haven't even talked
about tracking the changes between
frames as we are talking about video
animations I think it is now easy to see
that this is a hugely relevant problem
in the post-production of feature films
and now on to issue number two which is
subtracting indirect illumination from
this footage this is a beautiful light
transport effect where the colour of
different diffuse objects bleed onto
each other in this case the green color
of the background bleeds onto the karate
uniform that is normally a beautiful
effect that here it is highly
undesirable because if we put this
character in a different environment it
won't look like it belongs there it will
look more like one of those super fake
Photoshop disasters that we see
everywhere on the internet and this
technique offers a novel solution to
this keying problem first we are asked
to scribble on the screen and mark the
most dominant colors of the scene this
we only have to do once even though we
are processing an entire video as a
result we get an initial map where
we can easily fix some of the issues
this is very easy and intuitive not like
those long sessions spent with
pixel-by-pixel editing these colors are
then propagated to the entirety of the
animation the final results are compared
to a ton of already existing methods on
the market and this one smokes them all
however what is even more surprising is
that it is also way better than what an
independent art is produced which took
10 times that long similar comparisons
are also made for removing indirect
illumination which is also referred to
as color and mixing in the paper it is
also shown that the algorithm is not too
sensitive to this choice of dominant
colors so there is room for amazing
follow-up papers to make the process a
bit more automatic thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
you